now we cannot wait to see the memes that
will come from this photo so for those
who don't know toronto is currently
phasing out of cover lockdown that means
our sporting arenas are at very limited
capacity when it comes to fans in the
building but at last night's raptors
game versus the miami heat you better
believe toronto's very own drake made an
appearance even if it meant he was one
of only a few people in the stands he
must have been good luck though because
raptors won so there you go okay so
there you go but check out this photo of
drake taking the game alongside raptors
president must
say it for me
yeah i'm horrible with names they were
two of approximately 200 people in the
building now we're going to show you
this video shared by the bleacher report
where drake is clearly more into his
phone than the wraps
oh
it's drake
on his phone for just an instant
alongside basketball czar of the raptors
messiah yujiri
[Music]
three of maybe 150 200 folks in the
building
okay so leave it to the internet
because they like to speculate and they
had a lot of thoughts about drake who
was blankly staring at his phone with
twitter users suggesting he was reading
the rihanna and asap rocky pregnancy
news one twitter user wrote he was
unfollowing rihanna and asap during that
exact moment
so people are loving it
what do you think about the internet
like just absolutely loving this they
want that so badly obviously he probably
wasn't doing any of that but what do you
think people's love is for for uh drake
in this whole rana news
hey you know what i think it's it's one
of those things where
for some women they're probably like oh
vindication that all the things at the
end of the day drake's a father he has
his child he's probably very happy that
she'll have hers and at the end of the
day you know it's realizing that even
him being on his phone it's the humanity
of things we all jump on our phone and
moments were like okay i'm just let me
just do some
mindless
mindless scrolling
so drake's human
it's not true it's true i'm liking this
civil studios is saying was drake doing
wordle
could have been doing the world i feel
like i'm the only one who hasn't done
wordportal yet that's been like a
massive thing everyone i haven't haven't
gotten into it yet either right but
you've been seeing everybody on twitter
uh tweet i even saw roz do it he got in
on it he's uh seeing his results i
wouldn't be surprised it's very
engrossing if you haven't gotten into it
yet yeah i love it uh yeah so many
comments about what drake was looking at
on his phone i mean wow people are very
invested in something uh that he's
probably just doing nothing about
probably doing nothing i will say that
though like
if you're a dad of a new kid yeah
wherever you are
if if someone texts you like something
about your like oh he did this today he
did that thing that's all you're looking
at so maybe it was that who knows yeah
and just just to finish this off carla's
saying listen riri is girlfriend goals
material so i get it